Hallo, ich bin Peter Addison, willkommen zurück zu den
Denkerinnen und der Antike im
Mittelalter. Heute werden
wir über die islamische Welt sprechen.
Wir gehen von Indien aus zu einer
anderen nichteuropäischen Tradition,
offensichtlich der islamischen Geschichte und deren Rolle
von Frauen im Islam ist ein riesiges Thema und
nicht das, was ich
in diesem einen Vortrag ausführlich behandeln kann, und
passend zur gesamten Reihe
wird es natürlich eine Art
Zeitdruck geben, also sind wir nur  Ich werde
mich mit Frauen im mittelalterlichen Islam befassen, was
in gewisser Weise den Aufstieg des Islam
und auch die ersten paar Jahrhunderte der
islamischen Wissenschaftsphilosophie und auch die
Mystik umfasst, die, wie Sie sehen
werden, ein wichtiges Thema in diesem Vortrag sein wird
Ich werde nicht darüber hinausgehen, dass ich nicht
über irgendwelche Persönlichkeiten sprechen werde
, die nach dem 12. Jahrhundert oder so lebten,
außer einem modernen Denker namens
Fat in ihnen, und Sie sehen, wen ich beiläufig
erwähnen werde, also passt das irgendwie
in das Schema der Vorlesungsreihe ein  Es als
Ganzes und in gewissem Sinne könnte man sich vorstellen,
was wir in dieser Vorlesung tun,
als das Thema der letzten fünf
Vorlesungen, in denen wir Frauen
auf Latein getauft
betrachten werden  Leute wie Hildegard von
Bingen Haider, die Methode der Magdeburger
Margerite, Dichter und so weiter, und sie sind
nicht gerade bekannte Namen, aber wenn
Sie versuchen, an berühmte
mittelalterliche Gelehrte, Denker,
Philosophen, sogar Mystiker zu denken, würde ich wetten,
dass mehr Figuren aus der lateinischen Christenheit es tun
würden  mir als aus der islamischen Welt in den Sinn kommt
, und nachdem ich mich tatsächlich
einmal eingehend damit befasst habe, um einen Podcast
über Frauen in der islamischen
Geistesgeschichte zu schreiben, und ihn auch zur
Vorbereitung dieses Vortrags erneut aufgegriffen habe, muss ich sagen, dass
dies tatsächlich etwas schwierig ist
Sprechen Sie das Thema der Denkerinnen im
Islam nicht an, weil es nichts zu sagen gäbe,
aber es ist nicht wie im lateinischen Christentum,
wo wir erhaltene Werke einer ganzen
Reihe von Denkerinnen haben, die im
Grunde f  Vom 12. bis zum
14. Jahrhundert
schwebten die Figuren später in dieser Serie
herum, aber heute können wir
hauptsächlich über einige
verstreute Namen, allgemeine Tendenzen und
Trends in der Rolle sprechen  Frauen im
intellektuellen Leben und im Islam, und dann werden
wir uns auf eine Denkerin konzentrieren,
deren Name Radhiya war,
eine berühmte und wichtige frühe Mystikerin,
die eine Frau war, aber zuerst möchte ich die
Bühne ein wenig vorbereiten, indem ich über die
islamische Geistesgeschichte spreche  Natürlich
nicht sehr detailliert, aber nur um
es für Sie zu skizzieren, weil Sie vielleicht
nicht viel darüber wissen, und dann
werde ich etwas über die
Rolle der Frau im Islam und die klassischen
islamischen Quellen im Besonderen sagen  Koran
und Hadithe Wenn Sie nicht wissen, was Hadithe
sind, machen Sie sich keine Sorgen, ich werde es erklären, okay, also
lassen Sie
uns zuerst uns in Bezug auf Daten orientieren, also ist ein gutes
Datum, an das Sie sich erinnern können, wenn Sie an
die islamische Welt denken  622 n. Chr.,
weil dies das Datum ist, an dem der
islamische Kalender beginnt. Wie Sie vielleicht
wissen, ist der islamische Kalender nicht
derselbe wie der Anzeigenkalender, also der christliche
Kalender, den wir hauptsächlich in europäischen
Ländern verwenden, und im Grunde beginnt er
bei 622, es ist ein Mondkalender
Anstelle eines solarbasierten Kalenders
hält er nicht ganz mit dem Werbekalender Schritt.
Der Grund, warum 622 das Datum ist,
an dem der islamische Kalender beginnt,
ist, dass Mohammed Mekka
mit seinen Anhängern verlassen hat, um nach Medina zu gehen, und
so in a  Es ist wie die Gründung
der muslimischen Gemeinschaft, also stammen die Zahlen, die
wir uns ansehen werden, hauptsächlich
aus dem 8., 9., 10., 11., 12. Jahrhundert,
der klassischen Periode des Islam, die manchmal
als das Goldene Zeitalter des Islam bezeichnet wird und sehr
oft als das Hoch angesehen wird  Punkt für die
islamische
wissenschaftliche und philosophische Kultur Ich bin
nicht begeistert von dieser Denkweise
, aus Gründen, auf die ich gleich noch eingehen werde,
aber lassen Sie mich zuerst erklären, warum die
Leute
nach Muha so denken  mmad und seine Anhänger
brachten die Botschaft des Islam, Sie haben eine
Zeit, in
der sich die islamische
Herrschaft über ein riesiges
geografisches Gebiet unglaublich schnell ausgebreitet hat, so dass, wie Sie wahrscheinlich wissen,
das islamische Reich innerhalb weniger Generationen
den ganzen Weg von Spanien
im Westen bis nach Zentralasien reichte  Osten und
mit dem Islam die Ausbreitung der islamischen
Herrschaft, also die Ausbreitung des Islams ist eine
Religion, verbreitet das Arabische als Sprache,
und so haben Sie eine Situation, die ein
bisschen wie in der Antike ist, wo
Sie Griechisch als eine Art gemeinsame Sprache
für viele haben  Intellektuelle Bemühungen
über das Mittelmeer später
haben wir natürlich Latein im späteren
Römischen Reich, aber auch im
Mittelalter, wo zum Beispiel Gelehrte aus
Frankreich, England, jetzt Deutschland,
in Latein waren,
ähnlich wie Figuren aus Zentralasien und
Persien wie der große Philosoph
Avicenna  er hätte auf Arabisch geschrieben
, obwohl seine Muttersprache
Persisch war und Arabisch als
Lernsprache verwendet wird  ng in der gesamten
islamischen Welt und eines der Dinge,
die islamische Philosophie hervorbringen,
ist, dass es im 9. 10.
Jahrhundert eigentlich schon ab dem
8. Jahrhundert eine riesige Übersetzungsbewegung gibt
, in der Werke der griechischen Wissenschaft
und Philosophie ins Arabische
übertragen werden  Mehrere Generationen bis zu dem Punkt,
an dem im 10. Jahrhundert so
ziemlich alles von Aristoteles, das
wir heute haben, auf Arabisch existiert, also werde ich
jemanden wie den
Philosophen ah da da b aus dem 10. Jahrhundert oder den
Kommentator von Aristoteles aus dem 12. Jahrhundert finden
bis sie später
eine wirklich gute Auswahl an
aristotelischen Werken lesen konnten sowie viele
andere Werke aus der Spätantike und
klassischen Antike, die
ins Arabische übersetzt worden waren, wussten sie
etwas über Platon, wie wir später sehen werden,
wo die verschiedenen, weil wir wollen
über seinen republikanischen Kommentar zu sprechen,
und sie wussten etwas über die griechische
Wissenschaft, insbesondere Medizin und so weiter in
diesen wissenschaftlichen  Bereichen sehen wir tatsächlich
manchmal das Thema Frauen auftauchen,
so wird zum Beispiel besonders in der
Medizin ziemlich viel zu
Themen wie Dinah-Ökologie oder Embryologie gearbeitet,
also zum Beispiel Avicenna, den ich gerade
erwähnt habe,
er verteidigt eine bestimmte Position zu
dieser Frage  Ob
Babys in der Mutter auf der Grundlage nur eines
Samens gebildet werden, der vom Vater stammt, oder zwei
Samen vom Vater und der Mutter,
das ist eine Art klassische Debatte und
bereits in der Antike, weil Aristoteles der
Meinung ist, dass der Vater den alleinigen
prägenden Einfluss auf die ausübt  Fötus, während
Gallen dachte, es gäbe eine Zwei-Samen-
Theorie, nach der
der Fötus sowohl durch den
Einfluss der Mutter als auch des Vaters gebildet wird und
Avicenna tatsächlich A bis C
wie Galan verteidigt, so dass beide
den Einfluss der Mutter aufrechterhalten, was
natürlich  ist richtig, denn sowohl die
Mutter als auch der Vater spielen jetzt eine Rolle in der
Genetik.
Eine Sache, die Sie nicht sehen, geschieht genauso
wie Sie es nicht sehen  Wenn es im
lateinischen Kontext in Europa passiert, sieht man
Philosophinnen nicht im Sinne von
zum Beispiel weiblichen Kommentatoren zu
Aristoteles im lateinisch-europäischen Kontext,
da wir sehen werden, dass es dafür einen ziemlich guten
Grund
gibt, nämlich die Schulen und dann
Universitäten, an denen scholastische
Philosophie betrieben wurde, schlossen Frauen aus, und
es gibt etwas Ähnliches, das
in der islamischen Welt passiert, also gibt es die
Entwicklung von Schulen, die
Medressen genannt werden, wo die Leute
Religionswissenschaften studieren können, einschließlich
Jurisprudenz, und auch Logik und
andere Wissenschaften im Zusammenhang mit Philosophie lernen können, außer
diesen  Frauen nicht zugelassen haben, ist es möglich,
dass Frauen gelegentlich dort den Unterricht besuchten,
aber Sie haben keine große Rolle von
Frauen in solchen wissenschaftlichen
Kontexten, also wie wir sehen werden, ist die Rolle von
Frauen im intellektuellen Leben in der
islamischen Welt normalerweise verbunden  mehr
auf die Weitergabe von religiösem
Lernen und auch auf Mystik, und das
sind sozusagen die zwei Themen, die
wir sein werden  Ich schaue mir das in diesem Vortrag an,
obwohl ich unterwegs auch eine Pause machen werde,
um etwas darüber zu sagen, was wir
über Frauen im Kontext der Philosophie finden können.
Okay, das ist sozusagen der Kontext für das
intellektuelle Leben in der islamischen Welt
in Bezug auf die Rezeption des Griechischen
Philosophie und Denken und Wissenschaft, mit
anderen Worten, das Zeug, das wir
in den ersten drei Vorlesungen behandelt haben, aber
natürlich passiert mehr als das,
und es gibt einen Kontext dafür in der
islamischen Welt, der
insbesondere durch die islamische Offenbarung natürlich festgelegt wird, so
wir  Vielleicht möchten Sie dies unterbrechen,
um darüber nachzudenken, was der Koran über Frauen sagt
und auch, was die Hadith über Frauen sagen,
so wie ich sagte, Sie wissen vielleicht nicht, was
Hadith bedeutet, Hadith sind Berichte über
die Dinge, die der Prophet Muhammad
während seines Lebens gesagt und getan hat und  Sie
stellen neben dem Koran eine sehr wichtige zusätzliche
Ressource für das religiöse Leben im Islam dar,
also in der islamischen
Rechtswissenschaft, wenn Sie das argumentieren, zum
Beispiel wenn Sie th argumentieren  Wenn eine bestimmte
Aktivität verboten oder erlaubt oder
ermutigt oder erforderlich ist, können Sie
offensichtlich auf Passagen im Koran verweisen,
die etwas ausdrücklich oder implizit verbieten
, es erfordern oder was auch immer, aber wenn dies
nicht der Fall ist, können Sie auf diese
Berichte über Dinge verweisen, die der Prophet gesagt
und getan hat, wenn er es ist  als
Empfehlung einer bestimmten Praxis zitiert wird, dann
wird empfohlen, wenn er als kritisch gegenüber einer bestimmten Praxis zitiert wird, dann ist
ihm ein Gedanke entweder entmutigend
oder verboten, und die Weitergabe
dieses Wissens ist ein sehr wichtiger Teil
des islamischen religiösen Lebens und wir
lernen darüber  war eine Art
Religionswissenschaftlerin in den frühen Jahren des Islam, nachdem sich
die Sammlung von Hadithen bis heute entwickelt
hatte. Denken wir also ein
wenig darüber nach, wie Frauen in
diesen Texten sowohl im Koran als auch im
Hadith vorkommen
Vielleicht kommen wir jetzt offensichtlich
in einen sehr umstrittenen Bereich, über
den viel gesagt werden kann, so wie über jeden
religiösen Handel  Es gibt viele
verschiedene Vorstellungen über Frauen, die Sie
in diesen Texten finden können, sie können
miteinander in Spannung stehen oder auch nicht, also kann
es mehr oder weniger schwierig sein,
sie miteinander als miteinander in Einklang zu bringen,
und ich sollte sagen, dass ich  Ich bin kein Experte
für den Koran, also werde ich nicht versuchen
, Ihnen ein endgültiges Urteil darüber zu geben,
wie Frauen im Koran vorkommen und
welche Haltung der Islam gegenüber Frauen einnimmt, wenn
es nicht einmal so etwas wie
Singles gibt  Haltung gegenüber Frauen im Islam, aber
ich sollte zumindest ein paar
der bekannteren Verse im Koran
erwähnen, die mit Frauen zu tun hatten, also hier ist
einer davon, dies ist das 4. Kapitel des
Korans und es besagt, dass Männer für
Frauen verantwortlich sind  durch das Recht, was Allah einander gegeben hat
und was sie
für den Unterhalt von ihrem Vermögen ausgeben, so
rechtschaffene Frauen entwickeln die
gehorsame Bewachung und die Abwesenheit des Ehemanns,
was Allah sie bewachen lassen würde,
aber jene Drähte, vor denen Sie Zuwächse befürchten,
raten ihnen  dann verlasse sie
im Bett und schlage sie schließlich, aber wenn
sie gehorchen, suchst du kein Mittel gegen sie
, also ist das ein gutes Beispiel für zuerst aus
dem Koran, der
sozusagen nicht besonders feministisch aussieht, also
rät er Ehemännern, bestimmte
Maßnahmen gegen ihre Frauen zu ergreifen  wenn sie sich
so
verhalten, dass sie sogar zu Gewalt
gegen sie auffordern, wenn dies eine Art ist
, die Passage zu lesen, kann es sein, dass es sich von selbst
versteht, dass dies zunächst
einmal eine Übersetzung ist, nicht meine Übersetzung,
sondern nur eine Art allgemein gebräuchliche
Übersetzung und  jedes Wort und diese
Passage, die ich Ihnen gerade vorgelesen habe, könnte
anders übersetzt werden, es könnte bildlich gelesen werden,
es könnte als
Metapher verstanden werden, es könnte durch die Beachtung
des Ratschlags eingeschränkt werden, nur in ganz
bestimmten Situationen verwendet zu werden, also
sozusagen  Die oberflächliche Lektüre
davon mag irgendwie frauenfeindlich aussehen, es ist alles andere als
offensichtlich, dass der Khan
daher ein frauenfeindlicher Text ist, nur weil er
diesen Vers enthält, und es kann sein, dass er
m ist  Vielleicht ist es so offensichtlich, warum dieser Vers
kompliziert ist, aber ich muss Ihnen keinen
weiteren Vers geben, in dem es offensichtlicher ist,
dass die Situation komplizierter ist,
also hier ist es aus dem 24
ihre Geschlechtsteile zu betrachten und zu schützen
, was für sie reiner ist,
Gott kennt sich mit dem aus, was sie
tun, und sagt den gläubigen Frauen, sie sollen
ihren Blick senken und ihre Geschlechtsteile schützen
und ihren Schmuck nicht entblößen, außer dem
, was notwendigerweise davon erscheint,
und einen Teil davon einwickeln  ihre Kopfbedeckungen
über ihrer Brust und
ihren Schmuck nur ihren Ehemännern,
ihren Vätern, ihren Vätern,
ihren Liedern zeigen, wie ihre Ehemänner, Söhne,
ihre Brüder, die Söhne ihrer Brüder, ihre
Schwestern, Söhne, ihre Frauen, was
ihre rechten Hände besitzen, sind die männlichen
Diener, die kein körperliches Verlangen haben  oder
Kinder, die sich der
privaten Aspekte von Frauen noch nicht bewusst sind und sie
nicht mit den Füßen stampfen lassen, um bekannt zu machen, was
sie c  einmal von ihrer Verzierung, ok, also
nochmal, du liest nur so schnell, dass
du vielleicht denkst, oh, ich verstehe, was
hier los ist, das ist eines dieser Dinge, wo
Frauen gesagt wird, sie sollen sich irgendwie verhüllen
, und vielleicht tun sie das, aber wenn
du darüber nachdenkst  Ganz am Anfang
der Passage gibt es Ratschläge sowohl für Männer
als auch für Frauen, und die Ratschläge sind nicht nur
ähnlich, sondern wörtlich gleich, also
heißt es, Männer sollten grundsätzlich bescheiden sein
und Frauen sollten dies auch tun,
also könnte dies tatsächlich verwendet werden, um dies zu argumentieren  Der
Cron hat tatsächlich eine ziemlich glamouröse Stadt und
Behandlung von Männern und Frauen, und
außerdem gibt es andere Passagen
, die in gewisser Weise für
die Rechte von Frauen eintreten, wie zum Beispiel durch den Schutz
ihrer Erbrechte, es gibt
Verse, die Mohammed
nach Frauen offenbart wurden  kam irgendwie zu ihm und
beschwerte sich über die Art und Weise, wie sie
in ihren Familien oder in rechtlichen Zusammenhängen behandelt wurden,
und dann kam eine Offenbarung,
die besagt, dass die Frauen
bestimmte Rechte haben, also gibt es '
Im Koran gibt es reichlich Material, mit dem
man argumentieren könnte, dass es sozusagen eine
Verbesserung gegenüber dem früheren Zustand
der Frau ist, andererseits könnte man
auf diese Passage verweisen und sagen, dass
der Anfang sicher Männer und Frauen behandelt
par, aber dann sagt es viel mehr
darüber aus, wie Frauen sich verhalten
sollten, als über Männer, also kannst du
das irgendwie schneiden, wie du willst, also
werde ich nicht mehr darüber sagen,
ich versuche nur, das zu sagen  Wie ich denke
, bedarf es bei jeder religiösen Offenbarung hier einer
sorgfältigen Interpretation, und es
gibt natürlich eine sehr komplexe und
lange Tradition von Kommentaren zu diesen
Passagen und zu allen Passagen im
Koran, die mit Frauen zu tun haben, also ein
riesiges Thema für sich  das gleiche gilt für
den Hadith diese Berichte über Dinge,
die der Prophet sagte und tat. Ich
werde nicht wirklich auf alles eingehen, was ich tue.
Sie könnten noch einmal über Frauen sagen, das
wäre ein riesiges Thema, auf das ich mich
konzentrieren möchte  Eine Sache ist
insbesondere nicht so sehr der
Inhalt des Hadiths, sondern die Rolle der
Frauen bei der Übermittlung, und das ist
eigentlich ein sehr interessantes Merkmal
der Hadithgeschichte, weil, wie ich schon
sagte, in den Medressen, die
später im 11. Jahrhundert auftauchten
Frauen sind grundsätzlich davon ausgeschlossen,
und wenn wir uns einen islamischen Religionswissenschaftler vorstellen
, stellen
wir uns wahrscheinlich richtig einen Mann vor, aber
tatsächlich stellt sich heraus, dass in den frühen
Generationen, also den ersten Generationen
gleichzeitig mit
und nach ihm, viele der wichtigsten
Überträger sind  der Hadith sind Frauen und der
Grund, warum wir das wissen, ist, dass es, als
es begann, übliche Praxis zu werden,
diese Berichte über Dinge zu zitieren, die der Prophet
sagte und tat, besonders im rechtlichen Kontext,
aber auch in Streitigkeiten über ganz
allgemein eine Frau, wie z. B. was religiös
angemessen ist und was  nicht sobald
das als eine Art Beilage zum Koran zu einem weitverbreiteten Phänomen wurde
, gab es
diese Wucherung von Berichten  wo
nicht klar war, welche authentisch
und zuverlässig waren und welche nicht, und
so haben Sie die Entwicklung einer Art
spezifisch professionellen Gelehrten, des
Hadith-Gelehrten, dessen Aufgabe es ist,
Informationen über diese Berichte aufzuspüren und zu
überprüfen, ob sie vorhanden sind oder nicht  authentisch sind,
also könnte man das in gewisser Weise mit
der Art und Weise vergleichen, wie Leute darüber streiten, ob
ein bestimmtes Buch wirklich von Aristoteles ist oder nicht
, sagen wir, und so
könnten Historiker auf der Grundlage
des gleichen Stils oder wo der Mann hin und her argumentieren  einfach gut
zu kommen oder was auch immer, ob dieses
Buch eine Feuerseele ist oder nicht, die Leute
sind sich über diese Art von Frage die
ganze Zeit uneins und im Fall des
Hadith würden sie versuchen,
die Zuverlässigkeit eines bestimmten
Berichts sicherzustellen  sage gut, ich habe es von so-und-so gehört
und so-und-so ist eine zuverlässige Person und
so-und-so hat es von jemand anderem gehört
und sie sind auch eine zuverlässige Person und
Nachbar hat es von einer anderen zuverlässigen
Person gehört und so  auf die  Kette Die
Kette wird Asad genannt und wenn jeder
in diesem Knoten zuverlässig ist und es
auf jemanden zurückgeht, der anwesend war, als der
Prophet saß oder sagte, dass es etwas getan hat,
dann können Sie sicher sein, dass es
authentisch ist, also sagt der Prophet
etwas aus  die Anwesenheit eines
vertrauenswürdigen Begleiters, dieser Begleiter
, der es jemand anderem meldet, der
vertrauenswürdig ist, und so weiter, und tatsächlich geht in den
Büchern, die diese Berichte sammeln,
die enorm sind, jedem Bericht dies voran,
also heißt es, ich habe es von so-und- gehört  also
bestellen Sie von so-und-so ähm so und so weiter
und so weiter, hier ist der interessante
Teil und der Teil ist relevant für Frauen.
Viele der frühen Gefährten und anderen
Reporter sind Frauen und sie
gelten als zuverlässig, also Sie, wenn Sie  Verfolgen Sie
die Übertragungsketten dieser
Berichte, die sie durch Frauen durchlaufen werden, und
einer der wichtigsten
Hadith-Berichterstatter der ersten Generation war die Frau des Propheten,
seine Lieblingsfrau Aisha. Nun,
wir werden gleich darauf zurückkommen, aber das ist nur so
Das wichtigste Beispiel für ein
allgemeineres Phänomen ist, dass
Frauen an der Überlieferung von Hadithen beteiligt waren,
was dann auch interessant
ist, dass wir sehen, dass die
Beteiligung von Frauen nach ein paar
Jahrhunderten nachlässt, wahrscheinlich weil dies die
professionalisierten Hadith-Gelehrten
nicht waren  normalerweise Frauen, weil sie vielleicht herumreisen
mussten, um
Informationen zu sammeln, was
Frauen nicht so leicht tun konnten, und so hat man
eine Art Rückgang der Beteiligung
von Frauen, aber im Laufe der Jahrhunderte
sieht man auch, dass es oft Frauen
sind  Übermittler von etablierten Hadithen
an ihre Kinder oder an andere Gelehrte,
also im Allgemeinen scheinen Frauen früh und später
eine sehr
wichtige Rolle bei der Bewahrung und
Weitergabe von religiösem Wissen gespielt zu haben, und
das ist sehr wichtig, gut, das ist richtig,
weil diese Berichte wie ich  Ich habe gesagt, sind
zusammen mit dem Koran und der Grundlage dafür,
was als religiös akzeptabel
oder nicht in dem gilt  Islamische Welt, und dies ist
nur ein Beispiel für ein allgemeineres
Phänomen, vielleicht ist es das wichtigste
und auffälligste Beispiel, aber es ist ein
allgemeineres Phänomen, nämlich dass
Frauen mehr am religiösen Lernen beteiligt waren,
als Sie vielleicht erwarten, und dazu gibt es tatsächlich
ein paar Zitate  das ich
Ihnen gerne vorlesen würde, das ist von einer
modernen Gelehrten namens Nadia
Maria Sheikh, und sie sagt, die Beweise
zeigen, dass es auf der untersten Ebene der Gesellschaft mehrere Arten
und unterschiedliche Grade der Alphabetisierung von Frauen gab,
wie
z  Sklavinnen hatten Zugang zu irgendeiner Art
von Bildung und konnten zeitweise ziemlich
gelehrt sein, und Bildungschancen für
die Privilegierteren standen
einigen Frauen offen, die es zeitweise schafften,
in der Gesellschaft als Schriftgelehrte zu fungieren, und ein
gutes Beispiel dafür ist ein Gelehrter namens
Luke Nam  die im 10. Jahrhundert in Cordova lebte
und anscheinend eine
Schreiberin, eine Kalligraphin und eine Gelehrte war, und
es gibt tatsächlich einen netten kleinen
Radioclip darüber  at wurde vor
ein paar Jahren von der BBC veröffentlicht. Wenn Sie also
jetzt nach Cordoba googeln, erhalten Sie einen 15-
minütigen Radioclip, der von einer Wissenschaftlerin aufgenommen wurde
, die Primärforschung zu dieser Zahl durchgeführt hat,
und was sie getan hat. Das ist ziemlich cool, rate ich
Sie, um das zu überprüfen. Hier ist ein
weiteres Zitat. Es scheint, dass bestimmte
Familien aus Damaskus, Kairo und
Bagdad eine virtuelle Tradition der
Ausbildung von weiblichen Übermittlerinnen und
Überliefererinnen, mit anderen Worten Übermittlerinnen von
Hadithen, wie ich gerade sprach, gemacht haben und
dass diese weiblichen Gelehrten regelmäßig
ausgebildet und zertifiziert wurden  E-Mail und weibliche
Juristen und spielten daher eine
wichtige Rolle bei der Bewahrung
und Weitergabe islamischer Traditionen.
Mit anderen Worten, aber
neben der Bewahrung und
Weitergabe von Traditionen offenbart das sorgfältige
Lesen biografischer Wörterbücher
eine große Anzahl von Frauen,
die als beschrieben werden  Juristen, die
angeblich ein Kompetenzniveau erreicht haben, das sie zur Erteilung von Fatw qualifiziert  Mit anderen Worten, die
Gerichtsurteile, als der Gelehrte namens
Khalid anfing, finanzierbar zu sein, also
bezieht er sich unter anderem auf
diese biografischen Wörterbücher oder
Enzyklopädien, also gibt es ein ganzes Genre
von Werken, das etwas später in
der islamischen Welt auftaucht  Gelehrte
sammeln Informationen über frühere
Gelehrte und einige davon sind sogar
Sammlungen ausschließlich weiblicher Gelehrter,
also haben Sie einfach eine Frau nach einer Frau
nach einer Frau, die für ihr Lernen gelobt wird
, und es wird erklärt, was sie getan hat.
In vielen Fällen wären dies ID gewesen
Gelehrte, aber Sie haben auch weibliche Dichter,
Sie haben eine Kalligraphin, wie er
erwähnte, Sie haben Füße,
Juristen, also ist die Vorstellung, dass alles
religiöse Lernen nur für Männer sei,
eindeutig falsch und tatsächlich die Art von
enttäuschender Tatsache, die ich
zuvor erwähnt habe, nämlich das da  sind keine
weiblichen Philosophen, also gibt es keine weiblichen
Kommentatoren über Harris, alles, was ich
aus dem Mittelalter weiß, gibt es, glaube ich  Ein
paar Erklärungen dafür, zum
Beispiel gab es im Allgemeinen nicht so viele
Philosophen und es war ein
sehr spezialisiertes Gebiet, aber in
gewisser Weise denke ich, dass die Philosophie
hier eine kleine Anomalie ist, also wenn
man sich viele davon ansieht  intellektuelle
Traditionen der Literatur, wie ich sagte,
die Überlieferung von Hadithen und so weiter, die
religiösen Wissenschaften im Allgemeinen und die
Mystik, wie wir später sehen werden,
Sie haben tatsächlich Frauen involviert,
und daher bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob die
Philosophie ein wirklich repräsentatives
Beispiel dafür ist  Respektieren Sie
jetzt, ein Grund, warum es so viele
Frauen gab, die gebildet waren und die
besonders an der Übermittlung
von Hadithen beteiligt waren, ist jemand, den ich
zuvor erwähnt habe, nämlich Aisha, also war
dies eine der Ehefrauen des Propheten, und sie ist
für eine erstaunliche Zahl
der Idee verantwortlich  Mit anderen Worten, sie ist die erste
Reporterin, die offensichtlich viel
Zeit mit Mohammed verbracht hat und offensichtlich als
eine seiner Frauen, die
im Islam sehr bewunderte Persönlichkeiten waren  ic Welt galt sie
als äußerst vertrauenswürdig, und
wenn Sie also Ihre Herkunft nicht auf Aisha zurückführen könnten
, wird das zuverlässig, solange
jedes andere Glied in der Kette
zuverlässig war, und es gibt viele
interessante Dinge über sie zu sagen,
tatsächlich einer meiner Lieblingshadithe  wird
von Aisha berichtet und es ist derjenige, in
dem sie die Idee als lächerlich abtut,
dass man in die Hölle geschickt werden kann, weil man
eine Katze misshandelt
Thema, also
antwortete sie jemandem, der sagte,
weder ein Glanz noch eine stolze Person könne
religiöses Wissen lernen, und sie sagte,
wie gut die Frauen unter den
Anhängern dieses la Mar sind, sie fühlen sich nicht
schüchtern, während sie solides Wissen und Religion lernen,
und etwas bei weitem nicht  Für den Fall, dass sich
alle Berichte in Asien um Frauen drehen,
gab es Hunderte und Aberhunderte von ihnen,
also gibt es alle möglichen verschiedenen
Themen, wie ich gerade sagte, eines handelt von einer Katze,
aber einige von ihr interessieren  Stichhadithe für
unsere Zwecke handeln von Frauen, das ist eine
von ihnen, und hier ist eine andere,
Aisha sagte, die Dinge, die unbekannte
Gebete mit anderen Worten ein Gebet
ungültig oder unwirksam machen, wurden
vor mir erwähnt. Sie sagten, der Hund, der Esel und die
Frau unterbrechen das Gebet, wenn sie vorbeikommen
Vor dem Gläubigen sagte ich, Sie vergleichen
uns jetzt mit Massen und Hunden im Namen
Gottes. Ich habe gesehen, wie der Prophet seine
Gebete sprach, während ich dort auf dem
Bett lag, zwischen ihm und der Qibla, was
die Richtung des Gebets bedeutet,
und um es nicht zu tun  störe ihn, ich habe mich nicht
bewegt, oh ja, also, was ist hier los?
Ich bin sicher, Sie wissen, dass der Muslim
nach Mekka schauen soll, wenn er betet.
Tatsächlich wurde die Qibla an einem
bestimmten Punkt geändert, aber es spielt keine Rolle, um welchen Punkt es
geht  dass sie in eine bestimmte Richtung schauen sollen,
wenn sie beten, und
jemand sagte vor Mahisha, dass
Hundeärsche und Frauen, wenn sie sich
zwischen dir und der Richtung bewegen, in die du
blickst, als ob sie vor dir gehen
oder wenn sie es sind  S  Vor dir zu stehen
, was das Gebet zunichte macht, macht es
wirkungslos, und ich denke, man kann es
am Ton erkennen, dass sie sehr wütend
geantwortet hat, dass das nicht wahr ist, und dann hat
sie auch so geantwortet,
wie sie es als Ehefrau konnte  des
Propheten sagte sie, dass Muhammad manchmal
betete, wenn sie direkt
vor ihm war, und es störte ihn nicht
, sie würde sogar absichtlich still liegen,
damit es ihn nicht störte, damit sie
sich auf ihre persönliche
Erfahrung mit dem berufen konnte  Wenn der Prophet diese Idee ablehnt,
wird dies zu einer maßgeblichen Art der
Widerlegung einer potenziell frauenfeindlichen
Idee, was sehr interessant ist.
Zusätzlich zu diesen Arten von
Hadithen, in denen sie tatsächlich etwas
Positives über Frauen sagt oder frauenfeindliche Ideen ablehnt, haben
Sie nur die Tatsache, dass  Aisha
ist eine Art Paradigma oder ein Modell für
spätere Frauen und
gibt ihnen in gewisser Weise die Erlaubnis, Religionswissenschaftlerinnen zu sein.
Wir werden das tatsächlich
in einem Zitat sehen  t Ich werde
später in diesem Vortrag lesen, und das ist
etwas, das sich quer durch die
islamische Geschichte zieht, also gibt es viele männliche
Gelehrte, die berichten, dass sie
von ihren
Müttern oder von anderen Frauen etwas über die Religionswissenschaften und insbesondere über die Hadith gelernt haben
Bis zum heutigen Tag gibt es Frauen
, die das Recht geltend machen, sich
in der Wissenschaft zu engagieren, und hier möchte ich
erwähnen, dass ich einer modernen
muslimischen Gelehrten namens Fatima Mondesi versprochen habe, dass sie
tatsächlich vor etwa einem Jahrzehnt gestorben ist
und Soziologin war  und eine Feministin,
die einige sehr einflussreiche Bücher geschrieben hat
, die für eine feministischere Lesart
der originalen islamischen Quellen plädieren, und in
einem davon beginnt sie damit, über einen angeblichen Hadith zu sprechen, mit
anderen Worten, einen Bericht
über den Propheten, in dem die Unterstützung
authentisch sein soll  was er
sagt, dass diejenigen, die ihre
Angelegenheiten Frauen anvertrauen, niemals erfolgreich sein werden, und
sie war darüber verärgert, weil sie
tatsächlich sagt, dass sie es im täglichen
Leben gehört hat, wir zu sein  Als eine Art
Rechtfertigung für frauenfeindliche Einstellungen angesehen,
und so geht sie los, und wie sie
in diesem Buch erklärt, das
ausführlich darauf eingeht, hat sie erste Nachforschungen über die
Ursprünge dieses Hadith angestellt und entdeckt,
dass dieser mittelalterliche Gelehrte ihn so
ausgesprochen hatte  gültig und authentisch
hatte einen Fehler gemacht, weil tatsächlich die
Person, die den Hadith berichtet, also wenn Sie
der Kette zurück zu Muhammad folgen,
durch jemanden geht, der nicht
vertrauenswürdig ist, und sie sagt tatsächlich
etwas Interessantes darüber, als
sie ihn irgendwie zur Analyse von
ihnen rausschmeißt
Sie sagt, dass es der Hadith gewesen sein
soll oder vielmehr
Abu Bakr gewesen sein soll, der die
Propheten sagen hörte, dass diejenigen, die ihre
Angelegenheiten einer Frau anvertrauen, niemals Wohlstand erfahren werden,
und dann sagt sie, dass
mich als muslimische Frau nichts daran hindert  eine
doppelte historische und
methodische Untersuchung dieses Hadith und seines
Autors, ein anderer ist Abu Bakr und
insbesondere der Bedingungen, unter denen
er zuerst war  verwendet und was sie
weiterhin tun wollte, ist zu zeigen, dass Abu Bakr
tatsächlich beschuldigt wurde, selbst einen Meineid geleistet und
falsche Aussagen gemacht zu haben, und so argumentiert sie,
dass er im Allgemeinen nicht vertrauenswürdig war, und
argumentiert auch, dass er bestimmte Gründe hatte,
eine Art Erfindung zu machen
frauenfeindlichen Hadith, und deshalb behauptet sie,
dass wir ihn in den
Bereich der unsoliden Berichte über den Propheten verbannen sollten,
anstatt ihn authentisch zu behandeln.
Offensichtlich beziehe ich keine Stellung dazu,
ob sie in Bezug auf diesen
bestimmten Hadith, den ich gerade versuche, Recht oder Unrecht hat
Um zu veranschaulichen, dass es eine lange Tradition
von Frauen gibt, die sich mit Religionswissenschaften beschäftigen,
und es gibt auch eine lange Tradition, ich meine, ich
gebe Ihnen nicht nur ein Beispiel aus den
Anfängen des Islam mit Aisha und ein
sehr aktuelles Beispiel, es gibt eine lange
Tradition von Menschen, die den Hadith als verwenden
eine Art Anlass, um über die
Rolle der Frau in der islamischen Gesellschaft zu streiten,
und das Gleiche gilt natürlich für den Koran
selbst, wie ich mit diesen
etwas hart andeutete  Passagen
über die Frauen im Koran zu interpretieren, eines der
anderen Dinge, über die viele Gespräche sehen,
sind die Quellen im Koran und Hadithe
, die die Verschleierung von Frauen unterstützen
die, dass
relevante Verse offenbart wurden, es stellt sich
heraus, dass es nichts mit Frauen zu tun hat, die
Schleier tragen, sondern darum,
einen Vorhang zwischen der Vorsehung von
Frauen zu ziehen,
die ihm im Grunde keine Privatsphäre geben, um es kurz zu machen,
also nehme ich noch einmal keinen
Ich versuche nur darauf
hinzuweisen, dass Frauen immer
sehr engagiert in ihrer Art der
Interpretation dieser Religion waren und
oft sind es große Frauen, die
sich für eine weniger
frauenfeindliche Version der Welt eingesetzt haben  Islam okay
, das sind Hadith-Gelehrte. Ich habe bereits gesagt,
dass es eigentlich keine weiblichen
Philosophen als solche gibt, es sei denn, Sie betrachten
Mystiker als Philosophen, was ich
irgendwie tue  aber ich werde heute nicht darauf eingehen,
weil wir
in den nächsten fünf Vorträgen viel Gelegenheit haben werden, darüber zu sprechen,
aber bevor wir
zu den Mystikern übergehen, möchte ich
etwas über männliche Philosophen im
Islam und so weiter sagen  Sie dachten darüber nach, dass Frauen
das Thema aufgreifen, das ich angesprochen habe,
als wir über die klassische Antike sprachen,
also erinnern Sie sich vielleicht, dass der zweite
Vortrag über Plato und Aristoteles und ihre
Ansichten über Frauen war, also gibt es nicht viel
darüber in islamischen philosophischen
Texten, ich habe Avicenna bereits erwähnt  und
er ist ein Beispiel für jemanden, der oft
in einem medizinischen Kontext darüber
spricht. Wenn Sie Leute finden, die
Dinge über Frauen sagen
, denken sie vielleicht nur nebenbei an die Passagen in
Aristoteles, wo er das tut, aber
Gelegentlich sehen Sie Anzeichen einer
großzügigeren Haltung gegenüber Frauen, von denen
Sie vielleicht sagen würden, dass ich bereit wäre
, eine aufgeklärtere
Haltung gegenüber Frauen zu sagen, und eine davon  diese,
die eigentlich ziemlich schnell vergehen, also
werde ich nicht einmal ein Zitat vorlesen, weil
ich die Idee ganz
einfach vermitteln kann, ist in Alpha Bobby, ich habe
nie einen Chilenen gesehen, der im 10.
Jahrhundert im Irak lebte, also spricht er über
seine Theorie von  Intellekt, und er erwähnt so
nebenbei, dass, sofern Männer und Frauen die gleiche psychologische Kraft haben und sofern ihr Intellekt beide irgendwie aktiv sind, auf eine Weise, die
vom Körper frei und unbeeinflusst ist,
im Prinzip Männer und Frauen sind  das gleiche
in Bezug auf den Intellekt, also wird daraus nicht
wirklich etwas gefolgert oder
gezwungene Schlussfolgerungen gezogen, wie wir es vielleicht
wollen, aber die offensichtliche Implikation ist,
dass Frauen in der Lage sein sollten, genauso gut zu
philosophieren wie Männer,
jetzt bringt uns das zurück  zu einem Thema, das
wir ein wenig in der antiken Umgebung erforscht haben
, und auch in der klassischen Antike
konnte Peugeot das nicht zu schön darstellen,
also sprachen wir darüber, dass,
wenn Sie ein Teller sind,
Sie mi  Denken Sie gut, jeder hat eine
immaterielle Seele und Ihre Seele hat nicht
wirklich ein Geschlecht oder Ihr Geschlecht
gehört zu Ihrem Körper, was den
Intellekt der rationalen Seele betrifft,
der vielleicht sogar von einer
Person zu einer anderen Person reicht  so
dass die gleiche Seele
mit dem Körper eines Mannes in Verbindung gebracht werden kann und dass der Körper einer Frau,
soweit es diese Seele betrifft,
alle gleich sind und das ist so ähnlich wie das, was
er hier auf dem Foto sagt,
andererseits sollten wir uns daran erinnern, dass es
vollkommen konsistent ist  Mit diesem Gedanken
anzunehmen, dass, wenn eine
Seele mit einem weiblichen Körper verbunden ist, der
Körper irgendwie daran gehindert würde,
seine Kräfte voll auszuschöpfen, genauso wie das Tragen von
Isola, das mit einem nichtmenschlichen Tier in
gefangenen Philosophien verbunden ist, also wenn Ihre Seele,
wenn Sie wiedergeboren werden, und Ihre Seele
mit der Seele eines Hundes verbunden ist, dann
wirst du als Hund nicht philosophieren können und so eine
Art frauenfeindliche Einstellung
könnte im Prinzip die Seele an sich sein  Ich
könnte Philosophie machen, aber wenn
es mit dem Körper einer Frau in Verbindung gebracht wird
, sind Frauenkörper irgendwie defekt, also haben
wir Ideen gesehen, dass sie übermäßig feucht,
kalt oder was auch immer sind und das
Ihre rationalen Fähigkeiten irgendwie behindern könnte, also ist es nicht
so klar, ob wir unsere nehmen sollten  Fuß
ab, hier eine kühne Haltung einzunehmen,
wann
Philosophen und überhaupt das kein
Thema ist, über das
in der islamischen Welt viel gesprochen wird. Ich meine die Frage,
ob Frauen Philosophen sein können, und
das liegt zum Teil daran, dass der
Haupttext vorgebracht wird  Diese Idee aus der
klassischen Tradition ist natürlich die
Republik Platons, und Platons Republik
wird auf Arabisch nicht sehr häufig gelesen,
tatsächlich ist Aristoteles
auf Arabisch viel einflussreicher als Platon, soweit wir
wissen, gab es keinen einzigen Dialog
Platons, der war  vollständig ins Arabische übersetzt,
während Arizona, wie gesagt,
fast vollständig übersetzt wurde, also hatten sie
so ziemlich das, was wir von
Aristoteles haben, und als sie P lesen konnten  lato war
es normalerweise in Form einer Art
Paraphrase oder Zusammenfassung, aber wenn
wir zu Epochen kommen, die im 12
Der Grund, warum er das tut, ist,
dass er die Arbeit nicht bekommen kann. Die
Politik von Aristoteles, Euer Ehren.
Denken Sie daran, dass wir die Politik für
Aristoteles' Gipfel zitiert haben
er hat
keine Übersetzung davon, aber er
hat eine arabische Version der Republik,
wahrscheinlich die Zusammenfassung der Republik, und
so kommentiert er das stattdessen und in
diesem Kommentar kommt er zu dem Teil,
wo Plato für die Idee
argumentiert  Frauen können Philosophen sein und im
Februar unterstützt er diese Idee absolut
und tatsächlich scheint er noch weiter zu gehen, indem er
sich über die Tatsache beschwert, dass
Frauen oft in der Gesellschaft behandelt werden, und ich denke,
er meint seine eigene Gesellschaft  Als ob sie dazu
nicht in der Lage wären, schauen wir uns
diese Passage an, denn es
ist wirklich interessant, dass dies ein Kommentar
zur Republik ist, in dem wir sagen, dass Frauen,
insofern sie eine Art mit Männern sind,
notwendigerweise die
Menschheit teilen, also ist es offensichtlich, dass  Die
Frauen in der vollkommen gerechten Stadt,
die in der Republik beschrieben wird, werden
die gleichen Aktivitäten wie die Männer ausüben, außer
dass sie darin schwächer sind, sehr ähnlich
zu dem, was Platon ähnlich sagt, da einige
Frauen mit weiblichem Sand eine
lobenswerte Veranlagung haben, ist das nicht
unmöglich  es gibt Philosophen
und Herrscher unter ihnen, die Kompetenz von
Frauen ist jedoch in ungerechten Städten unbekannt,
da sie nur
zur Fortpflanzung aufgenommen werden und daher an
der Oberfläche des Dienstes ihrer Ehemänner stehen
und auf die Fortpflanzung und Pflege beschränkt sind, macht
dies ihre anderen
Aktivitäten zunichte  da die Frauen in diesen
Städten auf keine
der menschlichen Tugenden vorbereitet sind, ähneln sie häufig
pl  Ameisen in diesen Städten,
dass die Männer in diesen Städten belastet werden,
ist einer der Gründe für die
Armut dieser Städte. Was unser
Varieté hier also tut, ist, dass er
ein Thema aufgreift, das man sowohl bei Plato
als auch bei Aristoteles findet, nämlich  Sie haben
die vollkommen gerechte Stadt und dann haben Sie
diese anderen korrupten Städte, die
schlimmer sind, und er sagt, na ja, genau wie es
für eine vollkommen gerechte Stadt typisch ist,
Frauen als nicht gleich zu behandeln, weil er
tatsächlich sagt, dass sie schwächer, aber genauso
fähig sind  alles zu tun, was Männer
tun können, wie Plato vorgeschlagen hat, also ist es
charakteristisch für die ungerechte Stadt,
Frauen zu behandeln, als ob sie nur die Guten
für die Kindererziehung wären, um Kinder zu gebären und
Kinder zu zeugen, und er
sagt sogar, dass dies eine Art Belastung für die
Wirtschaft dieser ist  Städte, in denen Sie nicht
alle Ressourcen nutzen,
die Ihnen wieder zur Verfügung stehen. Dies ist ein Thema, das
wir bei Plato gesehen haben, und sie
behandeln Frauen effektiv so, als ob
sie nur gut wären, sich wie Pflanzen zu
verhalten, die sie r  Das mag seltsam klingen, aber
der Grund, was er denkt, ist,
dass, wenn Sie an den Unterschied
zwischen Pflanzen, Tieren und Menschen denken, das
Besondere an Pflanzen ist, dass alles, was
sie tun können, ist, sich auf
die richtige Ernährung und Fortpflanzung einzulassen, damit sie sie
aufnehmen können  Nahrung, die
Nahrung und Wasser aus ihrer Umgebung aufnehmen
kann, und sie können daraus neue Pflanzen machen, indem
sie Samen fallen lassen oder was auch immer,
und er sagt, ja, das ist
effektiv, wie wir Frauen behandeln, wir behandeln
sie, als ob sie Pflanzen wären, die nur gut sind,
um mehr Menschen zu machen  So zum Beispiel, dass
Sonnenblumen mehr Sonnenblumen machen,
also denke ich, dass dies ein erstaunlicher
Text ist. Ich meine, er klingt fast wie eine KI,
meine kurz zugegeben, und abgesehen von
der Sache, dass Frauen schwächer in der
Philosophie sind als Männer, klingt er fast
wie eine Feministin aus den 1960er Jahren, sagen sie
Nun, ist es nicht schrecklich, dass unsere
Gesellschaft Frauen behandelt, als ob
sie nicht in der Lage wären, die Dinge zu tun,
die Männer tun können, obwohl wir sie tatsächlich
kennen?  Dass sie dazu in der Lage sind,
weil sie Menschen sind und deshalb
rational sein müssen. Sie müssen intellektuelle
Fähigkeiten haben. Sie müssen in der Lage sein,
Philosophie zu
betreiben  männlichen Philosophen aus der
islamischen Welt, der sich mit der Frage
der Frauen befasst Ich möchte mit einem Blick auf die Person enden, die
ich für die interessanteste
weibliche Person aus der islamischen Welt halte,
zumindest seit der klassischen Periode, und
dies ist eine sehr frühe Denkerin namens Nadia
Sie ist eine der frühesten Mystikerinnen, also
eine der frühesten Menschen, die zumindest im
Nachhinein als Sufis bezeichnet wurden. Wie
Sie wahrscheinlich wissen, ist der Sufismus die mystische
Tradition des Islam und ging sogar davon aus. Sie ist
sowieso eine Art prägende Figur
, die die Vorlage dafür vorgibt  spätere Mystiker
und der einige der Themen festlegt, die
wir in späteren Mystikern finden, wie zum
Beispiel der Rumi, der berühmte persische Dichter,
oder der Jude, starb eine andere wichtige Sophi  e
und die andere Sache ist, dass er ist, also ist er
eigentlich eine Idee zitieren Eine gute Idee ist in
gewisser Weise eine Figur, die einigen
der Figuren aus der klassischen
Antike in der griechischen Welt ähnelt, in dem
Sinne, dass wir nicht wie Unfälle
überleben müssen  Abhandlungen von Anna Deena,
was wir passieren, das sind Berichte von anderen
Autoren, hauptsächlich Sufis, die
Dinge berichten, die sie gesagt und getan hat, einige
davon waren
ihr zeitlich sehr nahe, und
so könnte man meinen, dass sie
ziemlich zuverlässige Zeugen sind, aber um es
zusammenzufassen  Dass wir es hier mit
der Art von literarischem Konstrukt zu tun haben, bei dem
Rabia
zu einer Figur wird, die später von Sufis
sehr bewundert wird, und eines ihrer paradigmatischen
Modelle dafür verwendet, wie ein Sufi sein
sollte, ist eine Sache, die
an ihrer Darstellung von Rabia sehr auffällig ist  ist,
dass sie arm ist und arm anfängt
und arm bleibt, weil sie freiwillig
bereit ist, auf jede Art von Reichtum
oder Komfort zu verzichten. Es gibt viele Berichte über
sie, die das verstehen  Dea gegenüber
und die Grundidee ist eine, die
aus anderen mystischen Traditionen bekannt ist,
einschließlich tatsächlich indischer Abkehr von ihren
Traditionen wie dem Buddhismus, wie wir
beim letzten Mal so effektiv ihre Einstellung berührt haben,
auch wenn ich Gott haben kann, warum
sollte ich Geld wollen oder warum sollte ich
schöne Kleider oder gutes Essen oder was auch immer wollen
, und es gibt eine tolle Anekdote
über sie, die ich vorlesen möchte, in
der ihr
vom Gouverneur der Stadt Bossa im Irak ein Heiratsantrag gemacht wurde,
was offensichtlich eine Möglichkeit wäre
, sehr zu werden  wohlhabend, weil
die Gouverneurin Fossa eine wohlhabende,
mächtige Person wäre, und sie
schreibt ihm angeblich zurück und sagt, dass der Verzicht
auf diese Welt Frieden bedeutet, während das Verlangen
danach Leid bringt, zügeln Sie Ihre Wünsche
und kontrollieren Sie sich selbst und lassen Sie sich nicht von
anderen kontrollieren, sondern lassen Sie sie teilhaben
Ihr Erbe und die Angst des
Alters wie für Sie selbst geben Ihren Geist
dem Tag des Todes, aber was mich betrifft, kann Gott
mir alles geben, was Sie anbieten, und sogar d  Außerdem
gefällt es mir nicht, auch nur
einen einzigen Moment von ihm abgelenkt zu sein, das ist ein
klassisches Gefühl, also
sagt sie, mein ganzes Interesse und meine ganze Konzentration seien
Gott gewidmet, und es gibt nichts, was Sie
mir anbieten könnten, was vergleichbar wäre
ein Thema, das
wir mehrmals in der lateinischen
Tradition sehen werden, das erstens
Askese, eine Art Ablehnung der
Werte dieser Welt, aber zweitens
irgendwie versucht, Ihren
psychologischen Fokus auszurichten, oder vielleicht könnten
wir Gott Ihren Willen sagen  oder zu Gottes Willen
Gottes Realität und wie gesagt es gibt
viele Texte und die oder schreiben
todavia die ihm diese Idee vermitteln nur
ein paar davon die es wert sind zu
zitieren tut nichts anderes sie sind kurz
er sagte angeblich mein Anliegen ist es
unterzubringen  mich zu Gottes Brunnen, er
hat mich mit etwas anderem beschäftigt
als mit den greifbaren Dingen, die Sie sehen,
und dann mit einer anderen Sache, die sie
angeblich gesagt hat, wenn ein Mann die
ganze Welt besäße, die er wollte  Ich würde nicht reich sein,
weil es vergeht und vergeht, also ist,
wie ich schon sagte, eines der starken Themen in
den Berichten über Rabia, dass sie
tatsächlich praktizierte, was sie predigte, er
ging den Weg und sprach, um zu
reden, indem er in völliger Armut lebte und
dies  ist eigentlich ein Thema, das sich wieder
durch die gesamte Sufi-Tradition zieht, man
könnte hier wieder an
Verzichtsbewegungen in Indien denken, wie die Buddhisten
und die Jakobus, die auf Eigentum verzichten und
durch Betteln überleben oder durch
Almosen von Sympathisanten und
Unterstützern überleben, ähnlich wie BIA völlig
mittellos und freiwillig ist  und in gewisser
Weise ist das nur eine Art Ablehnung von
buchstäblichem Reichtum, der Sie von Gott ablenken könnte,
aber hier geht etwas
Subtileres vor sich, nämlich dass
Armut in einem
allgemeineren Sinne als eine Art Zerstörung oder
Vernichtung oder Ablehnung der Welt verstanden werden kann  Selbst
insofern, als das Selbst sich von Gott unterscheidet,
also ist dies eine Idee, die Sie besser sehr
stark in einem Autor bekommen, wie es
die Persi sein wird  Ein Dichter, den ich vorhin erwähnt habe, also
die Idee, dass man
seine eigene Realität irgendwie auslöschen sollte und sich selbst
nichts als die grundlegendere Realität übrig lässt, die
Gott ist, und es gibt wieder eine nette
Passage darüber aus den
Berichten über Abia, wo sie
berichtet hat, dass sie eine hatte  eine Art Gespräch
mit einer Stimme, die sie gehört hat, die die
Stimme Gottes ist, und sie fragt, wie sie
wahre Armut erreichen kann, mit anderen Worten, eine
Art Auslöschung ihrer selbst, in der
sie mit Gott vereint und vielleicht sogar
identisch mit ihm wird, und hier ist, was sie
hört  Gott zurück Armut ist die
Geißel unseres Zorns, den wir
den Menschen in den Weg gelegt haben, wenn nur eine
Haaresbreite zwischen ihnen bleibt und die
Vereinigung mit uns alles verändert und die
Vereinigung zur Trennung wird, denn für
dich bist du immer noch innerhalb von siebzig Schleiern der
Selbstexistenz  bis Sie
unter diesen Schleiern hervorgekommen sind und sich
auf den Weg zu uns gemacht haben und die
siebzig Stationen hinter sich gelassen haben, werden Sie nicht einmal gefüttert
, um von dieser Armut zu sprechen, die dies
ist  d einer interessanten Passage, weil
sie von FDS jemanden darstellt, der noch
auf dem Weg ist, sich einer mystischen Vereinigung mit Gott zu erfreuen,
und nicht als eine
Art vollendeter Mystiker, der dies bereits getan hat, aber
ich denke, in gewissem Sinne interessanter ist
die zugrunde liegende philosophische Idee, die es
ist  Dass du die Realität der Route erschaffen hast
und dann die göttliche Realität und Armut hier
wird als ein Aufgeben der
erschaffenen Realität verstanden, nicht nur im
konkreten Sinne, dass ich kein
Geld brauche und mit sehr wenig Essen auskomme,
aber es  Es ist fast so, als würdest du
diese Realität als solche ablehnen, als
würdest du sie nicht länger für
wirklich real halten, weil du
den Zustand erreichen willst,
mit nichts identisch zu sein.
Gott ist möglicherweise eine sehr radikale Idee,
also etwas später, aber immer noch früh mystischer
Sufi  Wissen ist berüchtigt dafür,
sein Gewand zu öffnen und zu sagen, dass in diesem
Mantel nichts als Gott ist, also mit anderen
Worten, seiner eigenen Identität mit
Gott dient und diese Art von pantheistischem
Trendwitz  Hin Sufismus ist etwas, das ihn
immer sehr kontrovers gemacht hat und
von anderen Religionswissenschaftlern verurteilt wurde,
aber Rabia neigt nicht dazu, ganz so weit zu gehen,
also behauptet sie nie ihre Identität
mit Gott wie Halogen, sondern neigt eher
dazu, ihre Beziehung zu Gott darzustellen,
die eine davon hat  die koranische Sehnsucht, also wenn
Gott die Geliebte ist, ist sie die Geliebte, die sie
sich nach ihm verzehrt, wo sie
sich irgendwie in ihm auflösen
möchte, und sie möchte alles aufgeben, was
sie von Gott trennt, was in gewisser Weise
bedeutet, sie sehr aufzugeben  sich selbst und
mit ihm identisch werden und dies ist vielleicht
das Team, das am stärksten
mit dieser Idee verbunden ist. Diese Idee der Beziehung der Mystiker
zu Gott als eine
erotische  weibliche Mystikerin,
denn wenn Sie sich vorstellen, dass Gott männlich ist
und natürlich wird er oft
zumindest mit männlichen Pronomen bezeichnet, dann
macht es für eine weibliche Mystikerin irgendwie Sinn
, über Gott nachzudenken  als ihre Geliebte, aber das ist
natürlich ein Thema, das man auch in männlichen Mystikern oft sieht. Auf
jeden Fall ist hier
eine letzte Passage von der Erde oder tatsächlich ein
paar Passagen, die diese
Idee ausdrücken, das Seufzen und Sehnen des
Liebenden Gottes wird nicht gestillt  bis
es in der Geliebten zufrieden ist und
sie wurde auch gefragt, ob sie Satan hasst
und sie sagte, meine Liebe zu Gott lässt keinen
Raum dafür, einen Satan zu hassen, und dann wurde sie
gefragt, ob sie den Propheten Muhammad liebt,
und sie sagte, das sei ziemlich
gewagt, oh Prophet  Gott, der da ist
, der dich nicht liebt, aber meine Liebe zu
Gott hat mich so besessen, dass es keinen Platz mehr gibt
, irgendjemanden zu lieben oder zu hassen, außer
ihm, okay, also nur eine
Art Vorgeschmack auf einige der Themen, die
wir sehen werden  später mit der
lateinisch-christlichen Mystik, weil diese
Vorstellungen über die Beziehung zwischen dem
Mystiker und Gott erotisch sind
, werden wir das bei einigen dieser
anderen Mystiker sehen, die im mittelalterlichen Europa lebten,
aber ich möchte nur kurz darauf eingehen  Eine
letzte Sache, bevor ich mit diesem
Vortrag aufhöre, ist eine andere Idee, die
schwer zu bewerten ist, wenn es darum geht, wo
diese Frauen in ihren eigenen Gesellschaften sitzen,
denn auf der einen Seite, wer scheint
nach allem, was ich gesagt habe, was
Frauen sind  erlaubt hier einen großen Spielraum der
Selbstdarstellung, also haben Sie wie
die Religionsgelehrten, die ich erwähnt habe, und
diese Mystiker, oder wir haben zwei
religiöse Paradigmen verehrt, und das ist
teilweise etwas, was ihnen aufgrund des Modells erlaubt ist,
das von Figuren wie Aisha bereitgestellt wurde  die
Frau des Propheten, ich weiß nicht, was alles
stimmt, es gibt etwas, das es in gewisser Weise
kompromittiert oder uns mit einem
Vorbehalt konfrontiert, nämlich dass trotz allem
das Schönste, was man über
eine Frau in der mittelalterlichen islamischen Gesellschaft sagen kann, ist,
dass sie es ist  Im Grunde wie ein Mann, also ist sie
keine Beute der Standardschwäche
ihres eigenen Geschlechts, sondern sie hat
ihr Geschlecht irgendwie transzendiert, nicht indem sie
das Geschlecht vollständig transzendiert hat, eine Idee, die
wir manchmal gesehen haben  Ke zum Beispiel
war aus dem indischen Kontext irgendwie uh,
aber transzendent, eine minderwertige Frau
zu sein, um wie ein Mann zu sein, und dies würde
durch eine andere Passage
über eine Idee gut veranschaulicht werden, und diese stammt von einem
Biographen ihrer Nan Khatai, der sagte,
Gott sieht nicht  auf die äußeren Formen
, dh Gott ist es egal, wie du
aussiehst, in diesem Fall ist es ihm egal,
ob du eine Frau bist, wenn es
zulässig ist, zwei Drittel unseres
Glaubens von Aisha zu vertrauensvollem Recht zu akzeptieren,
weil sie berichtet hat  All dies ist
authentisch,
dann ist es auch zulässig, einen
religiösen Vorteil von einer ihrer
Dienerinnen anzunehmen, die Rabia trifft, wenn eine Frau
auf dem Weg Gottes geht wie ein Mann,
sie kann nicht als Frau bezeichnet werden, also
lassen Sie mich den letzten Satz noch einmal lesen,
weil  Es ist so auffällig, wenn eine Frau
wie ein Mann auf dem Weg Gottes geht, dass sie
nicht als Frau bezeichnet werden kann, also
bringt dieser Satz wirklich das rüber, wovon ich
spreche. Wenn Sie also denken, dass eine
Frau eine herausragende religiöse Figur ist
oder vielleicht eine  Als herausragende Mystikerin oder
sogar herausragende Denkerin in irgendeiner Weise werden
Sie ihr Geschlecht irgendwie leugnen,
und es gibt ein weiteres Beispiel, mit dem
ich gerne enden möchte, und zwar etwas
später wieder eine mystische Figur namens Ahmadi,
die eigentlich anders als Rabia ist  Sie ist
eigentlich eine reiche Frau,
die zum Sufi-Pfad konvertiert, und
viele der Berichte über sie sind sehr
interessant und geschlechtsspezifisch, so
dass sie zum einen mit einer
Art mystischem Guru oder Lehrer in Verbindung gebracht wird,
der ihr auf dem Weg zum Mystischen hilft  Pfad,
obwohl sie verheiratet ist, im
Gegensatz zu Nadia, die sich daran erinnert, dass ich
das Heiratsangebot des
Gouverneurs der Büste ablehnen würde, also war sie
zölibatär, sie hat nie geheiratet, gutes
Geld ist verheiratet, aber sie lebt immer noch
als Sufi und sie hat diesen Sufi-Meister
und  Sie hat also diese Art von zwei Männern in
ihrem Leben, und es gibt tatsächlich eine Geschichte
darüber, die meiner Meinung nach ziemlich
aufschlussreich ist, nämlich die folgende, als er
durch einen Samen, der ihr Sufi-
Meister ist, nach Hesse kam  nahm ihren Schleier von ihrem
Gesicht und sprach kühn mit ihm, ihr
Mann Achmed war davon überrascht und
Eifersucht packte sein Herz, er sagte: Oh
Fatima, warum diese Kühnheit mit Ozzie,
also sagt ihr Mann im Grunde, warum
hängst du damit herum,
ohne ihren Schleier auf ihr  gesagt, so viel wie
du mein natürlicher Partner bist, ist er mein
spiritueller Partner durch dich, den ich
liebe, und durch ihn, mein reicher Gott, das liegt
daran, dass er meine Gesellschaft nicht braucht, und
du brauchst mich und eine weitere von ein paar
Passagen, die es wert sind, hier betrachtet zu werden
eine über einen Tapia, also ist dies ein
Bericht von Samurai namens Hassan aus
Basra. Ich verbrachte eine ganze Nacht und einen Tag
damit, dass Nadia über den Weg aus
der Wahrheit sprach, und es kam mir nie in den
Sinn, dass ich ein Mann war oder dass sie eine
Frau war  so eine Art typische
Geschlechterbeziehungen zu leugnen, es ist, als würden sie
nicht mehr zählen, weil sie aufhört
, eine Frau zu sein, insofern sie eine Sufi-
Meisterin ist, und dann eine andere Passage darüber,
wen IV, der von ihren eigenen gelobt wurde  Sufi-
Meister Abu Zeid sagte, wer auch immer
einen in Frauenkleidern verkleideten Mann sehen möchte,
möge ihn Fatima ansehen, und
das ist jemand, also sind das wirklich gute
Passagen, die meiner Meinung nach das Phänomen veranschaulichen, von dem
ich spreche, diese
Art von zweideutiger Haltung oder so weiter
Einerseits haben Sie begeistertes Lob
und Respekt für diese Frauen,
andererseits haben Sie diese anhaltende Einstellung
zu Geschlecht und Frauenfeindlichkeit,
sodass das Beste, was Sie
über eine Frau sagen können, wie ich bereits gesagt habe,
ist, dass sie effektiv ist  wie ein
Mann oder dass sie aufhört, eine Frau zu sein, und
eines der Dinge, die wir sehen werden, wenn wir
uns jetzt ins mittelalterliche Europa und die Christenheit bewegen,
ist, dass einige der weiblichen
Autoren
mit dieser Idee spielen wollten, also haben sie '  Wir sind uns sehr bewusst,
dass jeder sie als
Frau sehen wird, und sie könnten das irgendwie
in ihre eigenen Arbeiten einbauen, manchmal nutzen sie das
sogar aus,
indem sie das zum Beispiel als reine Frau und als
Inf sagen  Andere Menschen machen sie
besonders gute Gefäße, um die
sprechende Stimme Gottes zu werden, also lassen sie Gottes
Nahrung durch sich sprechen, weil sie
so sind,
zum Beispiel, wir werden sehen, wie sie beim
nächsten Mal damit anfangen müssen, und das ist
nur eine  Ich hoffe, die Wache
wird uns zeigen, dass sie natürlich eine der
wichtigsten mittelalterlichen Mystikerinnen ist, und
sie wird eine der beiden Figuren sein, die
wir uns in der nächsten Vorlesung
ansehen werden, zusammen mit Eloise, der Geliebten und
Schülerin der  berühmten Philosophen Peter
Abaelard, also werden wir mit diesen beiden frühmittelalterlichen
Intellektuellen aus dem europäischen Kontext
weitermachen, während wir
uns weiterhin mit Denkerinnen und der
Antike im Mittelalter befassen. Danke, und
ich hoffe, Sie schließen sich mir für den nächsten Vortrag an